thousands of families are waiting to
hear when they will be able to visit
their elderly relatives
in care homes the government's promised
a system of rapid testing in time for
christmas
so that they can see their loved ones
well my next guest
elenia angeli was arrested by police
after she tried to take her mom
tina out of her residential care home
earlier this
month lenie and her daughter leandra
are with us now as we look at these
images she can only begin to imagine
how her mum must have felt surrounded by
all that chaos
not knowing what was going on lots of
police cars
her daughter being arrested taken out of
the vehicle
you can see her daughter there in the
back of
the police car um elenia and leandra
are with us now elenia um goodness me
talk to me about what happened
well it was not definitely not
planned this um the whole thing
has been quite shocking and traumatic to
us as
a family um and we're aware that
this is happening nationwide um
we've had floods of um requests and
um people contacting us in exactly the
same boat and
also um families who have younger
members um like disabled youngsters
in care homes who cannot be visited so
i'm just very pleased really that this
has been
you know unfortunate and horrendous as
it was
um i'm very glad that this has come to
public attention that
there's a there's a catastrophic
collateral damage
being caused throughout throughout the
nation by these
um these measures that are in place it's
simply just
you cannot separate families who care
so so so much you know from their loved
ones
leandra i'm sure that you supported your
mum in in
trying to bring grandma out of the care
home
but do you in any way appreciate that
the position that the care home found
itself
in it's really interesting to ask that
question i think since this has happened
we've become quite um clued up on the
legalities of things
and what we've realized is that so many
of our relatives are
are being incarcerated and yes the
the um the blame lies at the government
but it also
blame is laid at the um at the feet of
the care home managers because under the
mental
um under the mental capacity act an
individual
is entitled to have freedom and to have
all care put in their best interests and
also under the
mental health act every single human
being in the world is entitled to a
family life
so currently our loved ones are
deteriorating some of them have died
not necessarily from covid they've just
simply lost the will to live
so i think what we're now being aware of
is that families are in a position to
sue
care homes for for corporate
manslaughter
and for psychological abuse so this is
what we are
what we have realized over these last
few weeks
how did how did it happen what happened
i'm guessing the care home must have
called
the police the police came to the
vehicle then what happened
and and what were you saying to your mum
at that time because i mean she's 97
isn't she
yes i think it was it was um badly
managed by
the staff member who um was always like
litter fused to already
um you know us as a family um being
very upset and we've gone in a very
positive manner
to visit because it was our last window
visit
um um until
the next lockdown um which was which was
due it was imminent
um so we had gone with like a tray of
cakes for the staff
and and gifts for my mother um
and it was it it it was not planned
and but i just saw my mother
um in the in her deteriorated state
through the window
and it was i think it was the the way
that i was spoken to by this
the admin staff member it wasn't even a
carer
um that it i just it was just like a a
white hot silver rage came over me
that you know how dare we be spoken to
like this
and we really i just wanted to hold my
mother and
which is exactly what i did once i
gained entry
because she was literally feet away from
us
um from the front entrance and i just
desperately wanted just to put my arms
around her and let her know that
we were still here and we still love to
desperately
um because i'm sure she she does she
feels abandoned she must do
and sometimes and there have been two
other instances that have come to
attention to us in the last few days a
police officer
who was visiting her mother in a care
home who stepped over the threshold to
hug her mother the patio doors are open
and her mother has been evicted from
that care home because the daughter
broke the rules now that daughter was a
police officer
and another lady who contacted us whose
daughter is is disabled she's in a care
home
her daughter has been restrained by two
care assistants because her daughter is
trying to hug her mother
and this has caused her mother to have a
mental breakdown she now has her own
crisis team
so this is affecting not only the people
in these care home settings but the
families too
so we are one of hundreds of thousands
of families in this position
and also my mother has been um
well she's been served an eviction
notice because i've actually stood my
ground
and refused to pay the fees so she had
she's actually due to leave the home
on the 21st of this month so she's had
an eviction notice i want to desperately
want to take her home and care for her
and literally we're having to jump
through all these
bureaucratic red hoops tape whatever you
want to call them
uh in order to to get her home and it's
just like
delay delay delay um even
though um the services are trying on our
behalf to get
my mother home it's there's still such a
quagmire
of um doubt and
misunderstanding i think and i think
what we have discovered as well
is we've known that the care system the
social care system hasn't really been
fit for purpose for a long time it
really relies so heavily on family
members to be there to care
and i think covid has been a stress test
to the system
and and we have to look at actually
radically changing the whole of the
social care system
because of what has been shown through
this current crisis
apparently it must have been just so
distressing for you i can't even begin
to imagine just how challenging uh
it was and and to see mom so distressed
as well um
thank you for taking the time to join us
this morning um hopefully she will be
able to come
home tina will be able to come home in
the next few days and be able to spend
time with her family thanks for joining
us appreciate it
thank you